[Musique]
salut huitième plus gros dans la série
de l'été de monsieur d'euros de quoi
va-t-on parler aujourd'hui
eh bien on va parler un peu de robotique
on a parlé beaucoup de produits beaucoup
de smartphones
là l'idée serait de revenir sur un
produit que j'ai rencontré il ya
quelques mois un petit robot très sympa
pour toute la famille sais pas si vous
avez un robot sais pas si ça peut vous
intéresser puisque au final la robotique
vous vous y intéressez oui ou non
en attendant ce qui est sûr c'est que la
robotique va arriver très très très
prochainement dans les années à venir
dans tous nos foyers
que ce soit pour les enfants les robots
ménagers il ya des robots ménagers il y
en a pas chez tout bon parce que tout de
suite c'est quand même cher mais bayonne
à voir partout des robots ménagers des
assistants pour la cuisine et assistants
10 36 à 6 ans de ça les robots vont
arriver de partout pour l'instant ratée
côté un peu plus ludique vous allez voir
je trouve un petit robot hyper cool de
sociétés high tech et je vous en parle
tous
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler de robotique on
va parler d'un petit robot qui est très
marrant qui s'appelle alpha un pro qui
est développé par la société une tech
alors à la fin pour il est ici peut
faire plein de choses se gâtent alors
c'est vraiment un petit produit
robotique pour faire rentrer je dirais
son premier robot chez soi l'idée
d'alpha un pro c'est vous avez des
patterns qui sont programmés le petit
programmation voulu fait de faire des
mouvements vous pouvez le faire avancer
et reculer et tourner faire des pompes
le faire danser
vous avez en tout 16 programme prédéfini
il y en a d'autres qui vont arriver à
l'avenir
alors ce qui est intéressant que ce
produit si vous voulez c'est attend un
produit robotique révolutionnaire très
clairement mais c'est un petit peu le
petit robot pour la maison plus dédié à
mon avis un public jeune des enfants
même les grands enfants comme moi
peuvent vraiment se marier avec parce
que il ya un côté super marrant on peut
faire une chose scolaire et c'est vrai
que c'est un produit qui est hyper ses
dix ans après voilà c'est vraiment un
côté ludique simple vous pouvez
retrouver sur amazon si vous intéresse
je vous ai mis la main dans la
description je sais pas si ça vous
intéresse la robotique si vous avez déjà
un robot comme celui là si vous
envisagez non si vous envisageriez d'en
avoir un donc mettez moi sans
commentaire parce que c'est vrai que la
robotique une chose qui se développe
énormément déjà pour le côté ludique
mais également pour un aspect un peu
plus familial assistant de vie c'est des
choses qui vont vraiment développé à
l'envi rond des années 2020
[Musique]
c'est magnifique qu'est ce qui est mieux
que de siroter un verre sur un transat
un jour d'été avec un grand ciel bleu
c'est juste magnifique
je vous recommande à franchement voilà
pour ce petit robot aujourd'hui josé
passé la petite série d'été c'est la
petite série d'été on parle de choses
que j'ai vu cette année dont j'ai pas eu
le temps de vous parler donc mais plein
de petits sujets comme ça à droite en
vrac il ya aussi d'autres sujets sains
plus d'actu que je vais tourner
actuellement tout de suite à travailler
aux champs train de tourner à côté mais
bon on revient un petit peu sur ce que
j'ai vu ta les puits qui m'a plutôt plu
ils ont donc j'ai pas encore eu le temps
de vous parler
c'était l'occasion de paris stand petit
robot voilà donc si vous intéresse vous
ai mis tout lien dans la description du
poste que vous en penser ce que je vous
dis la robotique c'est un truc qui
pourrait vous bottez de la rue de
focales vous vous projetez ou alors pas
du tout ce qui l'est moins c'est une
chaleur c'est incroyable est ce que vous
pourriez vous voir avec un petit robot
est ce que ça vous botte
et puis est ce que vous pensez comme moi
que la robotique m omniprésente
d'ici quelques années vous marquez tout
sans commentaire bien évidemment on
reste connectés il vous invite à vous
abonner à l'essai des jolies pouces et
puis je vous dis à très bientôt d'ici là
soyez sages et pour les soins vitaux